I want to talk to you about this this
project this movie that you're working
on because it's a it's something that
you and I have talked about because we
are friends we have dined together we've
hung out our wives have hung out it's
just pictures with big chalices and
candelabras
we did I had a suit of armor brought in
the corner you're talking about uh this
movie that you've made is a subject
that's near and dear to your heart it's
about being dads older dads old dads old
dads there was something that came about
by you know uh not getting my [ __ ]
together and having kids really late in
life like I'm 54 my kids are five and
two and
um I didn't realize like how much the
world had changed like my daughter's in
kindergarten now and I was in
kindergarten 50 years ago so just the
whole way that they teach like
everything literally I'd be like oh
you're in the jungle gym and she'd be
like it's called the structure
and then I'd be like yeah and then I'd
be like oh my God I said jungle am I you
know did I've said borderline racist now
like what did I just say and you just
start freaking out and uh
uh you know just sort of it's it lives
sort of in that world and then also all
of this this world now of where you know
you you go back into somebody's Twitter
account eight years and find a bad tweet
and they're like this is who this guy is
this guy's an [ __ ] and it's like I
always looked at it like you had to go
back eight years before this guy was an
[ __ ] that's a that's an amazing like
Lou Gehrig run of not being an ass if
you went seven years like this guy was
totally cool but in 2014 oh you know
that one random Wednesday he was really
in a mood yeah and and it was just weird
someone who I you know I lean left I'm
not 100 left it's sort of like you know
um I just thought that whole era was
really fascinating to watch people like
just trying to just sort of Ruin people
like I understood the beginning of it
when they were going after these
monstrous people but then it just became
this this you know like these Ticky tack
misdemeanors [ __ ] and they were just
like just burn them down I was like for
Frankenstein movie like they were all
coming up the [ __ ] Hill so
um it's sort of you know subtly lives in
that world too right and and and you
know one of the things that I relate to
you on is we both come from like I say a
similar part of the country
I'm a little bit older than you and but
I do relate very much when you talk
about being a dad uh
you often relate it to when you were
contrasted with when we were kids and
that's something that hits home with me
because you know I had kids later in
life now they're teenagers but in the
early stages I remember thinking this
does not resemble the childhood that I
have in any way yeah you know because
first of all the uh the fact that so
much care and attention is spent on each
child it's something that was no I'm not
saying that I love my parents but it was
a different attitude there were six of
us and I remember very clearly at any
given time if you ask my mother my
father you know where's Conan they'd be
like I don't know you know he's yeah you
know you know no one knew exactly where
you were they just sent you outside
like that was a lot of it they just sort
of sent you outside and you went out and
you just met other kids your age and
came up with stuff to do when you were
outside and then eventually you ran into
older kids and then they just beat the
[ __ ] out of you
and then this is where and then you came
up like that I did a cartoon for Netflix
called episode family one of the First
episodes is a scene where the young me
and his friend are up in a tree and
these guys start throwing rocks us and
shooting fireworks and that was based on
a true story there wasn't fireworks but
it was just me and a friend of mine were
climbing trees we're just climbing a
tree because that's what you did before
the no internet that was like that was
going online climbing a tree and risking
your life so we climbed up this tree and
these bigger kids came by and they saw
us up there and they just started
throwing rocks at us until their arms
got tired we're up there like Brian
getting hit in the ankles and in the
back and then you just climb down the
tree and then the ghost guys arousal but
I remember number that and I bring this
up because the minute that our uh my
daughter could drive or my my son could
drive my wife would check and she could
show me on the phone where they were
and I thought that's just blows my mind
it doesn't it doesn't shade Edgar Hoover
yeah yeah it doesn't feel right to me
that we are that accountable all the
time and sometimes I wonder if I'm just
jealous of there's it's there's a
different there's like a care and
attention I see what you mean do you
know what I mean and I wonder because
when I watch your comedy when I when I
watched you at Red Rocks and you're
talking about anytime you're talking
about your child your dad
how the how the house was tense or there
was anger people weren't dealing with
things appropriately uh I think yeah I
know what you're talking about was an
ERA and I think I sometimes when I'm
seeing my family and my wife's handling
everything so beautifully for some
reason I become enraged no I guess why
where was well what do you mean they eat
you're looking him in the eye and
talking to them what was this I totally
get that I'm about one time being in
like uh a grocery store or something
like that and I saw this this kid he
started crying about something and his
mother went over and started hugging him
and comforting him and I immediately I
just felt this urge to go over and trip
this little kid
oh my God and then
another time I remember
the grocery store because that's where a
lot of you know moms have like the kids
and stuff and this kid was going like
yeah Mom can I have candy and she was
just like no and then he started crying
and it made me laugh I was going to be
like yeah I get used to that kid
so
um so you enjoy
happiness and pain of a child I thought
I did but
that was just me with all of my [ __ ]
I was jealous of the kid who's getting
hugged and then I was laughing at the
other kid because I related like I
remember when a long time ago I saw a
sling blade when it was in the movie
theater and I remember when when when he
zoomed that guy out of the house in the
wheelchair he's like get out of my
[ __ ] house and he zoomed him out like
I was all helpless I roared with
laughter and I remember I was with you
these these actors that I was working on
stuff and they looked at me in this
horrified way right and I couldn't
explain you had to be a comedian to
understand like I think actors and
comedians they process pain differently
right where actors I think are more like
examining it where comedians you just
pave it over and it's like you're just
laughing not cause you're happy that
happened to someone in a wheelchair
you're just laughing just how [ __ ]
mean it was
I told you about this that one time my
wife was on the plane with me and she we
were going somewhere far so she had like
a tablet and I started watching a movie
and she had fallen asleep and I was I
was watching a movie and I was laughing
so hard I woke her up and then she you
know when you don't know what somebody's
laughing at you just start laughing
she's like what are you laughing at I
was trying to hide it and she looked and
I was watching precious oh my God God
oh my God
it was literally oh my God
some [ __ ] it just gets so mean it's just
so mean it pushes you through yeah into
comedy again she was the mother said
something so [ __ ] mean and then they
just cut to her face and she was
she was so sad I just I mean I'm not
gonna lie being honest I was wheezing I
was literally
so I was laughing so hard the woman I
didn't know on the other side of my wife
was laughing and then my wife started
punching me in the shoulder I just gave
it like the tablet
no she's so that's one of my favorite
things
and we're always watching TV and she's
forever getting teared up and I'm
laughing my ass off like she used to
watch The Biggest Loser and these these
fat people would be crying
how about all the cookies and burgers
they were eating
and they were crying like they lost a
dog or something and she would be crying
that I would just be laughing my ass off
so so no most of the world is starving
that's why
like I'm 50. I went to like India and I
saw this level of poverty that I just
maybe want to adopt every kid over here
and then you just come back to America
and this is slovingly feel oh you just
can't stop me ignoring you it was just
so [ __ ] hilarious oh and uh oh this
won't end and then no and then then it's
like
this won't and then what it is it's
because my wife will ever hear this my
wife gets mad at me for laughing it
makes it like
oh dude I have worse ones than that I
got worse ones
error
attack people
not gonna laugh at this one because
you're told you're not supposed to no no
that's not this crap some dude beat [ __ ]
out of his girlfriend right
you know how to get a crowd you have
them
you had them you're like yes I can top
that yeah
she's supposed to watch the news am I
really supposed to be going oh
time or you can laugh I mean it's a
choice I
have to like how does it help me but how
okay I wanted you to I want to hear you
pull this out so my wife was so sad
about it that I had to make a joke
because I wasn't mature enough to be sad
with her right so I was going like what
do you think she said what do you think
that that last thing she said right you
know yeah exactly so she gets all mad
right
[Laughter]
got really mad why did she marry you
she's lovely I've met her she's
wonderful like a week later my
mother-in-law comes over right
the [ __ ] story comes on the news
stories over she goes I know I shouldn't
say this
my wife goes mom don't say it and she
just goes I wonder what the last thing
she said
I died laughing my my mother-in-law died
laugh after my wife started
out of the room yeah but the end of the
day neither one of us beat her up so
like
she can't hear us laugh I'm not happy
that that happened well there's I don't
understand what the [ __ ] news is
it's a bunch of [ __ ] you can't fix that
happened that was horrible
do you know what my gym at my gym they
literally play CNN and it's just the
whole state of Californians on fire
school shootings and [ __ ] it's like I'm
coming in get away from this [ __ ] I'm on
a [ __ ] elliptical and I gotta watch
people's houses burning down right right
how long are you supposed you're trying
to make this seem like three hours on
the elliptical so we should be showing
like I don't know
Dumb and Dumber
I think this is going good
I think it's going great